I'm in the UK at penguin which I'm thrilled about because I
think penguin is the greatest book publisher in the world and and
England is the center of the English language, and that's really something because
England has brought a tradition of
Truth and clarity to the world that has illuminated it in many ways, and I'm hoping that this book
extends that great
English tradition one step farther like a good colonial should so
That's and I hope you
Read it and I hope that it helps you sort out your life
I think people have found the things that I have said helpful in that regard and I've tried to distill them and
Extend them in this book and deepen them so hopefully that's what you'll find when you read it